hello good morning everybody it's nice
to see you all here at 5 data Global
conference as Maryam said and Lalita
krishnamurthy I'm the CEO and co-founder
of open team global and I'm excited to
share with you some thoughts about
raising Awareness on iniquities of data
while we are building trustworthy
artificial intelligence models
to businesses and the World At Large
influencing life critical decisions such
as who gets a job who gets the loan and
what kind of medical treatment a patient
receives
that makes the potential risk of biased
artificial intelligence models even more
significant
the path to managing and mitigating this
risk begins with understanding how such
bias can occur and why it is so
difficult to detect and what this chart
just doing the basic math that I have on
this chart will tell you that more than
90 percent of businesses today
has AI embedded somewhere in their
journey and in their process
so AI is truly everywhere
this slide what I'm trying to capture is
from an overall Leader's perspective
there's actually three business outcomes
that bring the entire value of AI to
businesses today
obviously the first one is enhanced
decision making the second one is around
business transformation and the third
one surround systems modernization
AI promises a dazzling value Beyond
Simple automation right we've come way
past just using AI for automation
objective data driven and informed
decision making has always been the lure
of AI but brings with it the risk of in
somehow or the other getting biased into
these models
while that promises wouldn't reach
businesses should proactively consider
and mitigate potential risks including
confirming that their software doesn't
result in buyers against specific set of
people
and in this case I have some examples
here listed where it speaks to different
companies and businesses that have
actually used AI they've gone all in on
AI and have actually reaped various
benefits from using AI to drive their
business driven decision making
in this slide what I'm trying to show
you is where and how substantial AI
value is realized now across the board
you can see right from you know
productivity through automation through
improving customer service through
improving decision making we are seeing
AI play its part in almost every
different
pieces of the journey that a company
would have where they can actually use
AI to support their decision making
AI adoption has become positively
correlated with Superior business
outcomes in Revenue cost and
profitability and this finding holds
across Industries and also regions
to help for example I'll give you a
specific use case here to help optimize
pricing for example AI can input reams
of historical data on product sales
margins supplier costs and customer
satisfaction then produce rigorous
amounts and estimates of possible future
scenarios it can project how competitors
and suppliers might change their prices
in response to your decisions AI
combines with Internet of Things sensors
can forecast machine performance and
maintenance needs enabling better
operational decisions with the rise in
AI at the edge AI combined with that
Computing AI algorithms are executed at
or near live device levels these
decisions can make can be lightning fast
as well
so then let's talk about the real core
topic here right AI is powerful I think
we've established that we've talked
about the fact that it's extremely
helpful and helping leaders make very
data driven decisions we've established
that we've talked about specific areas
where AI has actually played a very
significant role in providing a return
on investment to businesses
then the question then comes up right
how do biases actually enter an
emotionless set of algorithms and to
explain this let me let me give you a
perspective here so people write the
algorithms people choose the data used
by algorithms and people decide how to
apply the results of the algorithms
without diverse teams and rigorous
testing it can be too easy for people to
let subtle unconscious bias enter which
then AI will automate and perpetuate
that is why it is so critical for the
data scientists and Business Leaders and
business leads and product owners who
develop and instruct AI models to test
their programs to identify problems and
potential biases
I'll give you a hypothetical example
here to to make the point on how
important it is and why AI sometimes
becomes biased I think the definition of
AI we understand AI bias it makes
decisions that are systematically unfair
to a certain set of people
so here's my hypothetical example
consider the hypothetical example of an
algorithm used to decide which patient
should receive expensive continuing care
for a chronic disease
the theme that creating the algorithm
decided to base their model on past
patterns of approvals for such care
they designed the algorithm to match
this historical data set so keyword here
is historical data set right however in
this illustrative example these specific
patients who belong to a specific set of
cultural regions some of whom speak
English as a second language and have
difficulty navigating or not familiar
with the U.S Healthcare System have
difficulty you know understanding the
overall system and infrastructure
historically only requested and received
this care for far more severe cases than
the specific chronic diseases that they
had
without awareness of this fact and a
determination to compensate for it the
algorithm will hypothetically continue
to assign the care for more rarely to
these patients effectively automating
discrimination
in this hypothetical example here
absolutely there was there is none of
the authors of the algorithm or the
business leads had any bias they just
neglected to evaluate the historical
data set to determine if there were
problems and if so to correct them
so this is the reason how and why AI
becomes biased in um in our process
now let's talk a little bit about why
addressing AI bias is so challenging
right we see the value of AI we see the
propensity for it to drive business
results we understand how AI bias is
entering into an emotionless
algorithm we understand how
um you know this this algorithm the
insertion of this bias into the
algorithm can cause some really damaging
results to the company
so then the question is why is this
addressing it so difficult
the fight against AI bias is filled with
good intentions right so Executives
understand the need for responsible AI
that which is ethical robust secure
well-governed compliant and explainable
so when there was a survey done a full
50 calls out responsible AI as one of
their key areas to focus for their
businesses as we go into the next year
as one of their top three priorities
but what we're starting to see is that
AI bias can be very difficult and it's
an unusual challenge because there's a
huge dependency on each organization's
algorithms the culture the diversity and
their stakeholders
there are also very few standard metrics
to measure fairness leaving each company
to kind of figure it out on their own
and in the absence of standards that
apply universally and the diversity of
the AI usage each organization should
determine what kinds of buyers are more
likely to skew the algorithms it uses
companies may also have to assess what
would potentially cause the most harm to
their employees customers communities
and business plans
there are ngos universities and
multilateral organizations around the
world that are today working to better
Define ai bias and layout principles and
guidelines to help mitigate this so is
it a challenge to address this bias
absolutely because a lot of it devolves
around the data sets the algorithms how
they are determined it also is dependent
on the organization's algorithm culture
diversity and stakeholders
so this leads us to a very interesting
concept about the need for us to
understand our actions so that the
better we understand our actions the
more capable we are to stop and to limit
and to be aware of the bias that we're
introducing into our AI systems so as AI
becomes more advanced humans are
challenged to comprehend and retrace how
the algorithm came to that result
the whole calculation process is turned
into what is commonly referred to as a
black box that is impossible to
interpret these black box models are
created directly from the data and not
even the engineers or data scientists in
our teams who create the algorithms can
sometimes understand or explain what
exactly is happening inside or how the
AI algorithm arrives at a specific
results
now this is because a lot of the data
like we talked about in the earlier
slide is historical data set that might
be decades old that a company has on
their legacy systems and some of it is
data that is just coming in through all
of their different channels that they
have for their business
so addressing these questions is the
essence of explainability and getting it
right is becoming essential while many
companies have begun adopting basic
tools to understand how and why AI
models
um render their insights unlocking the
full and why Ai and value of AI requires
a pretty comprehensive strategy and what
we're trying to explain here and show
you is um is that as we move into the
future we're starting to see a need for
machine learning techniques and
Frameworks that are more intuitive that
are autonomous that have neurosymbolic
ai built into them they are intelligent
and explainable machine learning models
where we're able to explain the reasons
and rationale for choosing a specific
data set and if you're able to trust the
results and the insights that's being
provided by the AI model
foreign
[Music]
I want to draw your attention to
something that um is an explainable
artificial intelligence model that I've
been starting to read up more and more
about coming from our Department of
Defense darpa's work that they're doing
and new machine Learning Systems they
have the ability and they'll have the
ability to explain the rational
characterize their strengths and
weaknesses and convey an understanding
how how
um they will behave in the future the
strategy for achieving their goal is to
develop new and modified machine
learning techniques that will produce
more explainable models like I said
earlier this is about us as data
scientists as AI professionals and
practitioners being able to explain our
actions behind the kind of data set we
use the algorithms we Define and the
decisions that are being given out by
the AI models that we use to make
business decisions these models are
going to be combined with like
state-of-the-art computer humor human
human computer interface technique
capable of translating models into
understandable and useful explanation
dialogues
and and the strategy that they're
proposing is to pursue a variety of
techniques in order to generate a
portfolio of methods that will provide
future developers and with a range of
design options covering the performance
and explainability as well so we're not
slowing down the model
um to in order to make it more
explainable
um this particular example that I have
here that I said the explainable
artificial intelligence is one of the
handful of current DARPA programs that
I'm aware of where you know they're
expected to enable like a third wave AI
system where machines understand the
context and environment in which they
operate and over time build underlying
explanatory models that allow them to
characterize real world phenomena
now I'll talk a little bit about
um our ability to have making your AI
responsible and what can we do as as
teams and and uh and developers
um around making your AI more
responsible
so I think it's a fact that AI has
become sophisticated enough to support
and make uh you know very important
decisions that requires rigorous and
sustained action to help them to help
make it trustworthy reducing bias and
possible risks such as buyers can bring
so um I want to share with you some best
practices some and some
um specific things that we can all do
um in your environment you know if
you're a data scientist if you're an AI
practitioner or if you're a business
lead or a product owner there are some
things that you can actually keep in
mind in order to reduce AI bias in your
models the first and foremost thing is
identifying you know your uh is around
thinking about your own unique
vulnerabilities
um so every business is different so for
example Bank retails utilities All Phase
different kinds of risks when it comes
from potential AI bias uh where it could
creep into data sets and algorithms
where it could
um cause major damage determining your
own company's unique vulnerabilities
understanding your own business model
and defining bias for your specific AI
systems is super important so calculate
the resulting Financial operational and
reputational risk that is to your
business and prioritize and focus the
mitigation efforts where they matter the
most
the other point here is around
controlling your data
like we talked about earlier there is
historical data sets that we use there
is real-time data that we use there is
data that you know at scale and the the
practice here is your traditional
controls probably are not going to be
sufficient
um and robust to detect the particular
problems that can be caused
um or causing the AI bias you should pay
special attention to issues in
historical data and data acquired from
third parties
um you know also be aware of uh proxies
or biased correlations in data sets that
might happen
um and uh for example you know if you
think that you're making your data
colorblind
um certain zip codes that may correlate
that data used in the algorithm is still
a lot of buyers to creep in
um so if well designed uh you will have
synthetic data created to fill gaps in
in your data set
um the other thing that you could do is
obviously you have to govern your AI at
AI speed as we know AI is always on and
may use data from across your
organization that you may or may not be
aware your governance should have your
model that you have your standards
governance and compliance models within
your companies needs to keep up with
this it should be continuous and
enterprise-wide this governance should
include easily understandable Frameworks
which and toolkits which allow you to
have common definitions and taxonomy and
controls in place so that you can spot
problems and your business users can
follow the rules
um so that this data and and the bias
data doesn't proliferate your entire
system so a systemic approach to
continuous management of your AI models
is absolutely required and critical for
you to build keep your business moving
forward
the other thing that I would stress on
is having uh diversity in your team
right and now it's become even more
important than anything
recognizing bias is often my belief is
that it's a matter of perspective and
people from different backgrounds from
different gender identities economic
backgrounds racial backgrounds we notice
something different and everybody
notices different biases so building
diverse teams will help you reduce the
potential risk of bias falling through
cracks and a diverse team will bring
together data scientists and Business
Leaders as well as professionals with
different educational backgrounds and
experiences
um such as sociologists it's lawyers
accountants each having a slightly
different perspective and lens on on the
bias and and what they would call a bias
and each will have their own view of
threat of bias and how to mitigate that
and finally this is about validating
independently and continuously and so
what this means is just as you would for
any major risk mitigation in your
business or in your work you typically
add an additional independent opinion
right you think about an independent
independent line of defense or you think
about bringing a third-party person with
the skill set and proven methodology in
order to get that opinion that is
sometimes required this line of defense
you know could continually analyze your
data and algorithms for fairness
um technology tools are evolving but
they're not at that point where they're
able to help you narrow this down
um but that is where some of the
programs like the one I shared earlier
about the explainable AI and other
efforts that are happening across can
help you
um reduce the AI bias so that you can
spot and understand inequities in your
data when you build out your AI models
um I want to share I had these these
couple slides here towards the end I
wanted to share this because I wanted to
give you a perspective of where there's
a lot of work and and effort that's
happening across on a timeline that's
happening across the world where this
building trustworthy AI models and being
able to enable leaders and and business
owners and you know universities and
academias across the world be able to
trust the decision making and insights
that are coming from their AI models
like we talked earlier right 93 of
companies around the world are saying
they already are on their journey and
they have ai embedded within their
businesses so it's no surprise that
they're actually making day-to-day
business decisions based on those AI
models so what it calls for and this
timeline actually shows you that from
2020 as early as 2020 when a lot more
awareness started around hey you know we
need to actually pay attention to these
decisions that are being driven through
these models to um to as recent
um as you know July and this year we're
actually starting to see a very very
intentional effort across the board so
just to call out a couple of things
right in September 2022 the Department
of Labor announced efforts to ramp up
reporting to protect worker organization
organizing so there's a very specific
move there in September to ramp up
enforcements of surveillance only
required surveillance reporting to
protect worker organizing in October as
early as just last month
um the uh there has been effort here in
the National Labor Relations
um Board of general counsel issued a
memo against unlawful electronic
monitoring and automated management
and so um the point of these two slides
is to give you the hope and to share
with you real data that there is
actually work happening across the board
um in an effort to minimize bias that is
going in and the inequities in data
that's resulting in bias in your AI
models and as we look at Future and
early 2023 the Department of Education
actually will release recommendations on
the use of AI for teaching and learning
and and there is a lot more of
um you know efforts that are happening
that are very intentional towards
reducing those bias
um here are some references I have on
topics
and I do want to share that
um you know the as part of open teams
Global uh in order to support our open
stores contributors around the world and
to help open source Thrive we launched a
Global Network of Open Source
contributors so the QR code here will
take you to our page and uh and if
you're interested you could join our
network of Open Source contributors
and um
there is an um open hours at the end of
our talk here uh with Travis myself and
Fatma where we'll talk about our open
source Professional Network our open
teams Enterprise solution architect
Network and also share
um best practices on how you can use our
open teams help score to pick the right
technology stack for your open source
projects
um
with that I want to say thank you to
everybody for your time today and
um and if there are questions I can I
can definitely take them
um through chat